the Palm Royale the most exclusive club
in the world was where I
belonged how did you get past security I
came in the back there are no doors on
the back of the
pomah I never said I use the
door I had only been in Palm Beach 2
weeks we don't know you I'm Maxine Dort
but I already knew the Palm
Royale the most exclusive club in the
world was where I belonged Evelyn you
are the woman to know in Palm
beig I don't like you Maxine you're very
good at making things awkward I don't
concern myself with the shenanigans of
vapid
poons what is Evelyn wearing
sleeves you know anything about rich
people I parked on the
lawn Robert shake me another martini and
then let's play
doctor do you work vaccine God no you
want to work God no you really want all
this more than anything I've ever wanted
in my whole life like to take a few
pictures Maxine you're the lead story I
see us all as one
Sisterhood are people looking for
something new let me tell you a little
something about Palm Royale it's a
nightmare and that's all thanks to you
don't underestimate a delic cour I would
never Palm Beach is just a shell game
everybody has a secret you to
behave you don't have to have money the
blackmail is right here you don't know
the half of it what you the fires of
pale pit is going on here off we
[Music]
go you're in over your head and girl you
don't even know
it I am never in over my head it would
be disrespectful to my hairdresser too
[Music]
sh in Palm Beach the secret is like a
loaded gun no no no no you never know
when it will go
off for who it might
hit
ladies I know yes surprised to see me
considering you left me for dead there
be some
[Applause]
[Music]
changes